jetzt sind das sind die sogenannten
risikogebiete bei allen die aus solchen
gebieten zurück kommen gehen wir auf
nummer sicher
schon jetzt gilt werden in zwei wochen
vor der einreise nach deutschland in
einem risikogebiet war muss sich in
quarantäne begeben oder ein testergebnis
nachweisen dass nicht mehr als zwei tage
alt ist
ich will das noch mal wiederholen weil
ich in mancher öffentlichen debatte den
eindruck habe dass das irgendwie gar
nicht mehr bewusst ist
es gilt schon heute wer aus
risikogebieten nach deutschland einreist
muss zwei wochen sich in quarantäne
begeben oder ein aktuelles negatives
testergebnis vorlegen zusätzlich habe
ich heute angeordnet dass ab samstag für
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten eine
testpflicht gilt das heißt wer aus einem
solchen risikogebiet kommt nach
deutschland einreist muss ein
testergebnis mitbringen oder hier in
deutschland einen abstrich machen lassen
ein test durchführen lassen
mir ist sehr bewusst dass das ein
eingriff in die freiheit des einzelnen
ist aber ich finde es ist ein zumutbarer
eingriff es ist mehr als nur eine
pflicht für den einzelnen für den
einreisenden urlauber denn es ergibt
sich aus meiner sicht aus einer
verpflichtung für uns als gesellschaft
aufeinander aufzupassen und sich
gegenseitig zu schützen
freiheit das ist jedenfalls mein
freiheitsbegriff heißt nicht immer nur
freiheit für mich alleine freiheit kommt
immer auch mit verantwortung
verantwortung für mich selbst und
verantwortung für andere und dazu gehört
eben auch im alltag aufeinander
aufzupassen oder wenn ich aus einem
risikogebiet zurückkehre nicht testen zu
lassen oder mich in quarantäne zu
begeben wir leben nicht in normalen
zeiten
wir sind als gesellschaft in einer
besonderen situation
lassen sie mich auch dazu noch ein paar
worte sagen wir alle wissen wir alle
sehen die pandemie ist noch da und sie
geht weiter aber nach all den wochen und
monaten setzt bei manchen eine gewisse
ermüdung 1
und es gibt das trügerische gefühl so
schlimm
war das doch bislang gar nicht das ist
menschlich und das ist verständlich
wir wollen alle unseren normalen alltag
zurück wir dürfen aber nicht vergessen
wir haben diese pandemie im
internationalen vergleich bisher so gut
überstanden gerade weil so viele
mitgeholfen haben gerade weil so viele
aufeinander aufgepasst haben weil wir
besonnen waren und wachsam und so neue
krone bunt studie zeigt die meisten
bürgerinnen und bürger in deutschland
unterstützen die maßnahmen im kampf
gegen das virus
das freut mich und dafür bin ich dankbar
maske tragen abstand halten für jene
regeln einhalten dieser regeln sind ein
kleiner preis wenn man sich anschaut
welche auswirkung ist auf eine
gesellschaft und auf den einzelnen hat
wenn das virus sich ungehindert
ausbreiten kann
und ich weiß dass die urlaubszeit für
viele die schönste zeit des jahres ist
für viele ist sie auch die belohnung
nach den entbehrungen der letzten monate
deshalb ist es mir wichtig noch einmal
an uns alle zu appellieren
geben wir weiter aufeinander acht
bleiben wir wachsam bleiben wir besonnen
halten wir die kleinen regeln des
alltags ein um uns insgesamt gegenseitig
zu schützen
denn da wo das virus eine chance hat
breitet es sich aus es nimmt keine
rücksicht auf urlaubsstimmung nicht auf
gewöhnung und nicht darauf dass wir
manchmal genervt sind
es kommt jeden tag auf uns alle im
alltag an
das war in den vergangenen wochen so und
das bleibt auch in den nächsten monaten
so kroner in schach zu halten das ist
ein langstreckenlauf
und es ist ein teamspiel es geht nur
gemeinsam
die erste frage hat herr matschinsky
herr minister sie haben es gesagt mehr
als 1000 neue infektionen ist erst mal
seit mai welche kennziffern und
schwellenwerte liegen sie dann zugrunde
um festzulegen ob wir uns in einer so
genannten zweiten welle befinden oder
nicht und berücksichtigen sie dabei auch
das verhältnis von durchgeführten tests
zu neu gemeldeten positiven fällen das
letzten teil habe ich akustisch
ehrlicherweise nicht verstanden
berücksichtigen
der letzte teil der frage es ging um das
verhältnis von tests die ansteigen zu
positiven fällen weil die positiven rate
ist ja noch unter mai wenn man dieses
verhältnis nimmt ok also die frage ob
wir in einer zweiten welle sind oder ob
sie kommt die halte ich für wenig
zielführend nur in dieser überschrift
geführt wir müssen tatsächlich schauen
wie ist die infektions lage wie gut
können wir umgehen mit den aktuellen
infektionszahlen etwas bedeuten sie für
das gesundheitssystem und für die
gesellschaft
und es ist schon so dass mit stand heute
um die 1000 neuinfektionen natürlich
unsere gesundheitsämter noch umgehen
können das was besorgnis erregt ist ja
die steigerung die wir in den letzten
tagen wochen gesehen haben und wenn die
sich fortsetzt dann wird eben
tatsächlich schwierig ein wichtiger
parameter ist und bleibt die frage wie
es mit der gesundheitlichen versorgung
ausgeht aussieht stand heute kann das
gesundheitssystem natürlich auch mit der
aktuellen infektions lage gut umgehen
wir haben freie intensiv kapazitäten in
ausreichendem umfang aber auch hier
sehen wir ja und haben wir in der
vergangenheit gesehen in dem moment wo
einmal die kontrolle nicht mehr da wäre
und das haben ja andere länder gezeigt
und zeigen im übrigen andere länder auf
der welt jeden tag wenn ich nach nord
oder südamerika schaue dann breitet sich
das virus eben sehr sehr schnell wieder
aus und dann kann es auch folgen hat das
auch folgen für das gesundheitswesen und
das ist natürlich ein sehr wichtiger
parameter für uns eine sehr berechtigte
frage hat die erhöhte zahl an positiv
testung auf was mit der ausweitung der
test kapazitäten zu tun muss man
sicherlich mit teilweise ja beantworten
wenn wir im moment etwa 100000 es
mehr in der woche machen als noch vor
drei vier wochen und wir in etwa immer
so 08 10 07 prozent positiv testung
haben dann sind 100.000 tests mehr pro
woche in einer infektions lage in einer
epidemischen lage in der wir sind dann
natürlich auch verbunden mit mehr
positiven tests die oder mehr
infektionen die wir entdecken deswegen
ist es sehr wichtig und deswegen aber
schönste bin ich sehr dankbar für die
frage dass auch entsprechend einzuordnen
ein teil der gestiegenen zahlen die wir
jeden tag sehen hat auch damit zu tun
dass wir mehr positiv positive fälle
mehr infizierte tatsächlich entdecken
das ist ja auch gut weil es uns hilft
infektionskette zu unterbrechen
die gleiche frage hatte auch julia
emmerich von funke gestellt ist damit
beantwortet dass sparen mich würde
interessieren wenn sich diese
anstiegsdynamik jetzt weiter fortsetzt
welche maßnahmen würden sie denn dann in
erwägung ziehen
und was kann man tun damit dann die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen
möglicherweise nicht so dramatisch sind
wie sie im frühjahr gewesen sind wir
haben ja auch hier viel gelernt lernen
können über dieses virus vor allem auch
wo es sich schnell ausbreitet und wo es
eben auch eine besondere herausforderung
ist und das ist insbesondere ich habe
vorhin die ausbruch situation hier
beschrieben es sind familienfeiern nicht
selten um die es geht religiöse feiern
bei denen sich einfach weil man eng
beieinander ist wenn man möglicherweise
ausgelassen ist weil man feiert sehr
schnell viele infektionen ergeben können
wenn 12 infizierte in der gruppe dabei
sind das sind tatsächlich auch religiöse
veranstaltung pfingstgemeinden ob nach
dem zuckerfest dort nach einem
kirchenbesuch wo wir das sehen da wo wir
auf engerem raum zusammen sind es sind
bestimmte betriebliche situation
insbesondere wo im betriebsalltag
abstand und bestimmte auch lüftungs
regeln nicht eingehalten worden sind sie
in der fleischverarbeitenden industrie
wo wir das gesehen haben wurde es sind
insbesondere gemeinschafts 1 3
und deswegen ist aus meiner sicht auch
sehr klar wenn die zahlen steigen dann
ist uns der erste fokus natürlich auf
die frage sein welche art von
veranstaltungen kann stattfinden welche
art von feiern welche art von
feierlichkeiten von so zusammenkünften
kann stattfinden
das ist aus meiner sicht auch etwas was
wir gelernt haben in den letzten monaten
das ist der hauptfokus auf dem wir
achten müssen
aus heutiger sicht und mit dem was wir
wissen auch zu dem nutzen von masken im
alltag zum beispiel glaube ich nicht
dass man nochmal so umfangreich
geschäfte schließen würde
da wäre sicherlich nicht der hauptfokus
die frage von dana bethkenhagen vom
tagesspiegel an ist dann auch ein
genereller lockdown grundsätzlich wieder
vorstellbar wissen sie viel wichtiger
finde ich ja die frage wie wir gemeinsam
verhindern überhaupt wieder in eine
solche diskussion zu kommen und es ist
ja nicht besonders schwer
es bleibt immer wieder bei diesen aha
regeln alltags maske hygieneregeln und
abstand halten
und ich weiß herbsttage schon mal gesagt
mit mich nervt das masken tragen auch
manchmal aber es ist eben notwendig und
ich finde dass masken tragen das
manchmal so eine kleine belastung im
alltag ist für die unbeschwertheit des
alltags ist im vergleich zu all dem und
das zeigt ja die frage was folgen könnte
wenn wir nicht aufeinander aufpassen
ein sehr mildes mittel und deswegen
werde ich anstatt in der theorie darüber
zu philosophieren was alles sein könnte
sehr dafür dass wir gemeinsam
aufeinander achtgeben und viel dafür tun
dass wir gar nicht darüber nachdenken
müssen weil es eben gemeinsam verhindern
durch niedrige infektionszahlen der
nacht wichtigste frage es gab zwischen
den koalitionsparteien eine einigung für
einen pakt für den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst wo der bund die
kommunen mehr unterstützen wollte und wo
eben auch die frage der bezahlung und
langfristigen festen einstellung von
neuen personal heute gespielt hat wie
ist da der stand auch speziell mit blick
auf die bezahlung
zuerst einmal möchte ich kenne die
gelegenheit nutzen
nochmal ein sehr großes dankeschön an
die vielen beschäftigten im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst in den
gesundheitsämtern vor ort in den
kommunen in den landkreisen und
kreisfreien städten zu sagen viele haben
ein stück erwartet und erwarten dürfen
aus dem was wir wussten dass es im
sommer vielleicht die möglichkeit gibt
zu einem innehalten und kraft tanken
nach sehr herausfordernden monaten für
alles was möglicherweise im herbst und
winter kommt und jetzt sehen wir mit den
infektionszahlen müssen weiterhin sehr
aufmerksam und aktiv bleiben das heißt
eben das seit vier fünf monaten in allen
gesundheitsämtern die beschäftigten dort
sehr intensiv auch übers wochenende
durcharbeiten und dafür ein großes
dankeschön ich bin auch sehr dankbar
dass die kommunen das war ja auch eine
zahl aus dieser tage die sich ergeben
hat aus einer abfrage umfrage der
kommunalen spitzenverbände bis zu 6000
neue beschäftigte jetzt auch in dieser
zeit in den gesundheitsämtern tätig sind
und dadurch eine stärkung in der arbeit
vor ort schon stattgefunden hat auch
durch das umstellen
in der personalplanung vor ort aber das
ist natürlich jetzt nur in der akuten
lage so deswegen haben wir vereinbart
bundesregierung die ministerpräsidenten
in zusammenarbeit mit den kommunalen
spitzenverbänden in einem pakt für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst ihnen
auch mittel und langfristig stärken zu
wollen ist finden in diesem monat
regelmäßige gespräche statt zum auftakt
habe ich mit landesministern und den
vertretern der kommunalen
spitzenverbände darüber gesprochen wir
sind im ständigen austausch miteinander
auf allen ebenen und unser ziel ist zum
monatswechsel august september ein pakt
für den öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
vorzustellen der beinhaltet die frage
der personellen ausstattung die frage
der bezahlung die sie angesprochen haben
weil es zum beispiel für ärztinnen und
ärzte im öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
im moment stand heute im schnitt
deutlich geringere
verdienstmöglichkeiten gibt als etwa in
einem krankenhaus oder in der praxis es
geht um die digitale ausstattung der
gesundheitsämter wir machen da jetzt
schon seit einiger zeit auch mit viel
erfolg
wenn ich das sagen darf auch was die
laboranwendungen angeht die nicht mehr
per fax sondern digitalen meldung von
infektionen
und andere mehr große fortschritte aber
es geht natürlich darum auch langfristig
die gesundheitsämter den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst zu digitalisieren
es geht um aus- und
fortbildungsmöglichkeiten es geht
übrigens über die aufgaben des
gesundheitsdienstes über
infektionsgeschehen hinaus was wenn
manchmal vergessen wird in der aktuellen
diskussion zum öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes ja nicht nur in
anführungszeichen für
infektionsgeschehen masernausbrüche oder
aktuell corona zuständig sonst kommen
was prävention angeht was
vorsorgeuntersuchungen angeht was
hygiene überwachung angeht ja viele
zusätzliche aufgaben mit der arbeit des
gesundheitlichen gesundheitsdienstes
auch die wollen wir stärken also ziel
ist zum monatswechsel tatsächlich einen
gemeinsamen pakt zwischen bund und
ländern unter beteiligung der kommunalen
spitzenverbände zu haben und dass der
bund in den nächsten jahren bereit ist 4
milliarden euro in den kommunalen
gesundheitsdienst zu investieren zeigt
er tatsächlich wie wichtig uns das thema
ist die nächste frage die gefahr
beschrieben die jetzt zum ende der
schulferien aus diesen risikogebieten
kommen können sie ermessen wie der
prozentuale anteil der infektion die
wenn deutschland registrieren durch
solche reisen kommen oder was wir hier
auf einem topf akquiriere dann an
erkrankungen eine frage eine zweite
fachleute sagen ja eigentlich müsste man
zwei mal testen weil ja der erste test
um eine momentaufnahme ist warum keine
zweite testung pflicht mäßig also zuerst
einmal ist es tatsächlich so dass mit
den zahlen und dem was wir
nachvollziehen können müssen ja immer
auch nachvollziehen können dann
infektionsketten weiterhin das ist auch
wichtig für die einordnung der großteil
der infektion innerhalb des landes
innerhalb von deutschland stattfindet
das sind die ausbruchsgeschehen die ich
gerade beschrieben habe wir sehen
gleichwohl mit steigender mobilität
steigen im reiseverkehr eben auch dort
steigende zahlen übrigens sehr sehr
wichtig im moment vor allem steigende
zahlen aus
mit reisen verbunden aus dem westbalkan
ländern insbesondere auch dem kosovo
oder serbien und in teilen auch der
türkei und wir sehen eben insgesamt dass
es bestimmte ausbruchsherde ja auch
innerhalb der europäischen union gibt
wir haben ja zum beispiel teile
nordspaniens auch wieder zum
risikogebiet erklären müssen wegen des
infektionsgeschehen es dort oder
antwerpen in diesen stunden weil dort
eben die zahlen entsprechend hoch sind
und das ist dann eben sozusagen die
zusätzliche vermeidung und die
vermeidung von zusätzlichen eintrag ins
land durch reiseverkehr aber wichtig ist
dabei nicht aus dem auge zu verlieren
was wir auch ein ausbruchsgeschehen im
land haben und deswegen auch das will
ich noch mal ausdrücklich sagen
angesichts mancher forderungen dieser
tage haben wir bereits mit der test
verordnung die anfang juni in kraft
getreten ist auch sehr umfangreiches
kostenloses präventives testen in
anderen bereichen möglich gemacht eben
gesundheitswesen vor jeder aufnahme
eines patienten eines pflegebedürftigen
wird zum beispiel getestet die
beschäftigten im gesundheitswesen können
viel umfangreicher als vorher auch
kostenlos getestet werden und anderes
mehr
um auch dort entsprechende angebote zu
haben
die frage der zweiten test um die sie
ansprechen ist eine die die
gesundheitsbehörden auch nach unserer
test verordnung und nach der rechtslage
anordnen können
das ist ja tatsächlich so wer den ersten
test durchführt dann ist ja auch keine
kenntnis darüber da wären möglicherweise
positiv getestet ist bzw wer überhaupt
getestet wurde und aus einem
risikogebiet eingereist ist
und dort kann dann eben auch eine zweite
testung entsprechende angefordert werden
einige bundesländer haben das ja auch
schon beschlossen ich finde nur eins
sehr sehr wichtig mit dem was wir schon
die letzten tage sehen mit positiv
testung bei den reiserückkehrern die in
relation höher sind als wir sie bei den
testungen im inland haben also im inland
haben war ja etwa ich habe vorhin gesagt
so 0 8 prozent ein prozent der
getesteten sind positiv bei den
reiserückkehrern sehen wir im moment
jeder flughafen und situation aber 1 2
zum teil über zwei prozent der
getesteten sind positiv also relativ
mehr dass wir allein durch diese
zusätzlichen tests und tests angebote
schon deutlich mehr entdecken an
infektionen als wir vorher entdeckt
haben und das ist für sich genommen
schon ein sicherheitsgewinn und dann ist
eben jeweils durch entscheidung der
behörden vor ort ein zweiter test auch
an ortbar anordnung spa kann angeordnet
werden zu den test hat auch andrea haase
rück vom deutschen ärzteblatt eine frage
bei den corona tests von rückkehrern
wird oft von mehreren institutionen und
verbänden der niedergelassenen
ärzteschaft darauf verwiesen dass die
festgelegten 15 euro vergütung nicht
kostendeckend sein wie wir das bmg
sicherstellen dass die leistungen
trotzdem flächendeckend angeboten wird
gut das ist natürlich eine diskussion
die wir in manchen bereichen haben über
die angemessene vergütung 15 euro extra
budgetär ohne anrechnung auf irgendwas
anderes ist im vergleich zu vielen
anderen bereichen der ärztliche
vergütung jetzt auch eine größenordnung
die sich zumindest gut einordnet ins
gefüge
unser ziel ist ja vor allem dafür bin
ich den kassenärztlichen vereinigungen
und den landesbehörden aus sehr dankbar
das ist es zentren gibt wo es also nicht
darum geht dass im einzelfall mal jemand
einzeln in der praxis getestet wird das
ist auch möglich und wird immer mal
wieder passieren sondern dass vor allem
auch regionale testzentren wurde dann
tatsächlich im idealerweise dann auch
viele hintereinander getestet werden
können
die 15 euro daneben doch auch sehr
auskömmlich sind ich verstehe dass
einige ärzte sagen wenn das immer im
praxisalltag dann auf einmal mittendrin
zu einem solchen test um kommt der muss
entsprechende schutzkleidung anlegen
dann ist das ein besonderer aufwand
deswegen ist unser ziel auch das hier in
absprache mit den ärzten und ärzten und
den kassenärztlichen vereinigungen vor
allem eben gezielt an testzentren und
gezielt in entsprechenden test
sprechstunden mit diejenigen hinein zu
steuern die getestet werden wollen und
die 11 6 11 7 zb als entsprechende
telefonhotline der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung hilft genau dabei dort einen
termin zu bekommen
red
ich hätte eine praktische frage ersparen
wie schnell muss man denn ein negatives
testergebnis vorlegen muss dass muss ich
mich da direkt am flughafen testen
lassen oder oder habe ich noch eine
gewisse zeitspanne zeit diese pflicht zu
erfüllen das ist dass die eine frage
wenn ich darf noch eine zweite
wer zahlt denn jetzt diese pflicht tests
und die gelten ja auch nicht für die
leute die in die türkei reisen weil die
müssen ja in der türkei bezahlen also
zuerst einmal muss derjenige der aus
einem risikogebiet einreist dann wenn er
dazu aufgefordert wird zum beispiel am
flughafen durch die zuständigen behörden
entweder den nachweis haben dass ist die
sozusagen regel situation die
vorgeschrieben ist den ärztlichen
nachweis über die entsprechende testung
und die negativ testung haben und wenn
er sie nicht beibringen kann dann in dem
zeitpunkt zu dem zeitpunkt eben die
abstriche in name auch dulden
also man kann nicht sagen ich mache das
dann in zwei tagen vielleicht mal
sondern zum zeitpunkt der aufforderung
die aber bis zu zwei wochen nach
einreise auch erfolgen kann
war ja tatsächlich ist eben auch ein
reisen gibt die ja nicht über den
flughafen direkt erfolgen sondern per
auto aus anderen situation heraus eine
entsprechende aufforderung zum nachweis
oder eben zum erdulden so heißt es im
gesetzestext zum erdulden einer
entsprechenden testung und ärztlichen
untersuchungen dann notwendig ist das
ganze ist bußgeld bewehrt wie es alle
regeln im infektionsschutzgesetz im
übrigen sind und im übrigen wer nicht
getestet wird und aus welchen gründen
auch immer entgegen der pflicht kein
nachweis hat muss zwei wochen in
quarantäne die regelung bleibt auf jeden
fall ja auch nach landesrechtlichen
bestimmungen entsprechend erhalten
und da die abstriche entnahme werk eine
blutentnahme sondern ein vergleichsweise
milde milde eingriff ist ist mein
eindruck dass die allermeisten das dann
tatsächlich in der situation auch
tatsächlich durchführen lassen werden
weil eben ja mit der negativ testung
dann auch die quarantäne
entsprechend verkürzt werden kann man
muss ja in quarantäne bleiben bis das
testergebnis vorliegt doch das ist immer
mal wieder wichtig darauf hinzuweisen
was die frage der finanzierung angeht
sind diese tests mit dem umfasst was
letzten samstag in kraft getreten ist
nämlich eben den kostenlosen testen für
alle reiserückkehrer dass wir
grundsätzlich mittelfristig das hat sich
dieser tage schon mal gesagt und
mittelfristig meine ich nicht über
nächstes jahr sondern die nächsten
wochen da hin kommen sollten als
europäische union und das macht nur
gemeinsam sind bei einreisen aus
drittstaaten von nicht eu bürgern einen
testung vor abflug zu verlangen das ist
jedenfalls meine feste überzeugung die
vereinigten staaten genauso wie china
denken genau darüber nach praktizieren
das in teilen auch schon das vor
besteigen des flugzeuges die
entsprechende testung zu erfolgen hat
und eine einreise dann eben nur mit
negativen test möglich ist jetzt darüber
wird nachgedacht und ich finde wir
brauchen als europäische union genau
dafür eine lösung
letzter teil das was sie angesprochen
haben bezüglich der türkei ist die
vereinbarung die wir politisch mit der
türkei auch haben das eben tatsächlich
rückkehr nach deutschland aus der türkei
wegen auch der besonderen situation die
es da gibt es viele eben die hier in
deutschland leben viele bürgerinnen und
bürger aus verwandtschaftsbeziehungen
familiären beziehungen
freundschaftlichen beziehungen heraus in
diesen wochen auch in der türkei sind
und das ist dann eben tatsächlich zum
gegenseitigen schutz auch sinn macht
entsprechende testung auch schon in der
türkei zu machen minister bei rtl n tv
eine frage in drei teilen sie hatten
eingangs die ende der ferien und den
schulstart angesprochen da wäre der
erste teil der frage sind die schulen
und länder da gut genug gewappnet was
ist ihnen dahingehend wichtig zweiter
teil in den
im bereich der test lehrer werden
regelmäßig getestet im klinikalltag gibt
es diese möglichkeit für das personal
nicht immer unbedingt zumindest aus nrw
und berlin wissen wer da gibt es
aussagen dass ärzte und krankenpfleger
in quarantäne einfach schlichtweg nicht
möglich sind die frage was halten sie
von so einer aussage wie kann man
klinikpersonal gegebenenfalls ein
bisschen besser schützen und das dritte
nochmal zur einreise wie gut ist das
bisher an den einzelnen flughäfen mit
der testung tatsächlich möglich wir
haben eine rückreise familie in berlin
begleitet die kam um 21 uhr an 20 uhr
war der test schalter leider zu wie geht
man damit um
das wäre es dann geschehen vielen dank
müssen sich immer alle berlin dann als
beispiel für ihre berichterstattung
neben also es ist ja so dass tatsächlich
fast allen flughäfen sowie wir auch die
rückmeldung haben von den kolleginnen
kollegen aus den ländern mittlerweile
entsprechende testzentren also flughäfen
mit entsprechend reiseverkehr muss man
ja auch dazu sagen
entsprechende tests zentren eingerichtet
sind dass das vielfach auch sehr sehr
gut läuft sagte aber auch dazu und das
muss man auch verstehen und da will ich
auch alle vor ort stechen ergreifend in
schutz nehmen das aufzubauen und dann
auch in den kapazitäten zu erweitern
ich finde das ist schon ein ziemlicher
windeseile mit beeindruckender
geschwindigkeit gelungen
aber am anfang bei einer solchen
maßnahme und da wo er im zweifel dann
auch viele das dann auch witz testen
wollen sich testen zu lassen von denen
die aus nicht risikogebieten
zurückkehren
das ist da ein wenig ruckelt zu beginn
das lässt sich nicht ganz vermeiden
deswegen kann ich einfach nur bei um
verständnis bitten bei denjenigen wo
sich auf wartezeiten ergeben oder auch
vielleicht zu beginn jetzt ein paar
anrufe mehr dass man wirklich dann die
entsprechenden ansprechpartner gefunden
hat aber alles in allem so sind die
rückmeldungen so ist das was wir sehen
haben wir in allen flughäfen zug um zug
und zwar von den kleineren mit
internationalen verkehr bis zu den
beiden ganz großen münchen und frankfurt
eben den aufbau der entsprechenden test
kapazitäten und der möglichkeiten was
die frage angeht im klinikalltag
beziehungsweise auch pflegekräfte
ärztinnen und ärzte in der altenpflege
wie im gesundheitswesen ist das eine
frage auch der jeweiligen infektions
lage vor ort auf anordnung der
gesundheitsämter was ich auch wahrnehme
ist dass es eine gewisse zurückhaltung
gibt diese anordnung zu machen und ich
möchte mit meinen kollegen in den
ländern auch darüber reden und wir nicht
für bestimmte bereiche sozusagen muster
anordnungen muster situationen haben so
dass das einzelne gesundheitsamt vor ort
tatsächlich auch leichter eine solche
anordnung auch regelhaft treffen kann
wenn das eben angeordnet wird vom
gesundheitsamt wir zur übernommen
aber diesen schritt braucht ist und ich
stelle eine gewisse unsicherheit ich
nachvollziehen kann vor ort fest und das
denke ich werden wir adressieren in den
nächsten
in den nächsten tagen und die frage des
schulbeginns die kolleginnen und
kollegen in den ländern die
schulministerin und schulminister wie
auch die kolleginnen und kollegen die
zuständig sind für die kindergärten und
kindertagesstätten haben sich ja sehr
intensiv in den letzten wochen mit
diesen fragen beschäftigt entsprechende
konzepte wurden erarbeitet
und jetzt werden wir alle miteinander
wie das immer es mit konzepten in der
theorie in der praxis ja sehen was im
zweifel noch ein stück besser geht aber
ich finde die konzepte für sich genommen
sind erst mal überzeugen darüber zeug
mit einer zielrichtung überhaupt
unterrichtung täter wieder möglich zu
machen denn das war ja eine der großen
herten auch der letzten monate für viele
in deutschland ob es die eltern sind
oder die kinder das eben schule und kita
nicht möglich war
das waren für berufstätige eltern auch
für viele viele andere war ja auch
ansonsten viel an steht dass man über
den tag so regeln muss und dann noch in
der frage so viel miteinander zu sein
ohne dass mal die möglichkeit ja über
viele wochen bestand mit anderen
haushalten überhaupt kontakt zu haben
das war eine sehr sehr große und ist bis
zum teil bis heute sehr sehr große
belastung ist meiner festen überzeugung
ist es eben auch wichtig für kinder
kontakt zu anderen kindern zu haben sich
austauschen zu können und eine frage von
chancengerechtigkeit im übrigen
homeschooling ist immer so schön gesagt
aber das geht bei weitem nicht bei jedem
zuhause aus den unterschiedlichsten
gründen frage von chancengerechtigkeit
für die kinder und jugendlichen das
unterricht wieder stattfinden kann und
ich finde angesichts des aktuellen
infektionsgeschehen ist ja richtig und
wichtig dass mit den konzepten auch
unterricht wieder startet und beginnt
und wir haben ja ich habe morgen mit
meinem britischen kollegen auch über die
schulfrage telefoniert und wir haben
festgestellt dass wir in deutschland
jedenfalls ein unterschied haben der in
dieser sage hilft wir haben 16
verschiedene schulbeginn und dadurch
können wir alle miteinander schrittweise
ja auch in den nächsten wochen lernen
was noch besser geht an eine frage von
markus wacket von reuters dazwischen
dies sichergestellt dass gerade die
türkei rückkehrer die teilweise auf dem
landweg kommen sich in quarantäne
auflagen und die testpflicht halten
zuerst einmal ist sehr sehr wichtig
immer wieder aufs neue darauf
hinzuweisen dass die quarantäne pflicht
schon seit vielen monaten gilt das aber
eben ein problem gewesen ist etwa
insbesondere bei der einreise auf dem
landweg dass wir sie haben sehr sehr
schwer nur überhaupt durchsetzen können
es gibt schon mal sagen viele wissen das
gar nicht es gibt schon seit vielen
vielen wochen und monaten die
verpflichtung für jemanden der aus dem
risikogebiet einreist sich bei seinem
zuständigen gesundheitsamt vor ort zu
melden
dass er jetzt da ist oder sie und dann
tatsächlich eben über kärnten und
weitere massnahmen zu reden
das ist auch tatsächlich fielen bisher
nicht bekannt und deswegen macht
jenseits der theorie ich kenne ja all
die theoretischen fragen und die
wichtigen auch ökologischen fragen zu
zweit testung aber deswegen macht in der
praxis die testpflicht und das
testangebot bei der einreise im
vergleich zu dem was bisher gelebt wurde
tatsächlich ein echt großen
sicherheitsgewinn
denn das eine sind ja die vorgaben die
wir tatsächlich rechtlich haben das
andere ist wie weit sie tatsächlich auch
bewusst sind und umgesetzt wurden viele
informieren sich halten sich daran
dafür bin ich sehr dankbar bei viele
bürgerinnen und bürger wissen zum teil
gar nicht dass es etwa diese
verpflichtung gab und gibt sich zu
melden
und das ist eben dadurch jetzt auch
durch die entsprechenden kontrollen
möglichkeiten die übrigens auch im
infektionsschutzgesetz angelegt sind
in dem entsprechenden paragrafen etwa
bei den einreisenden durch die
bundespolizei zum beispiel auch
kontaktdaten zu erheben und
weiterzugeben an den zuständigen
behörden dann tatsächlich eben auch
besser nachvollziehbar in stichproben
aber die allermeisten regeln in
deutschland werden per stichprobe
kontrolliert und das finde ich in einem
freiheitlichen land auch angemessen
alles andere würde zu ganz anderen
zuständen für ersparen in den letzten
tagen ist ja die schutzmaske noch mal
als so eine art wunderwaffe in den
vordergrund der diskussion gerückt die
leopoldina empfiehlt es jetzt im
schulklassen ab der fünften
jahrgangsstufe auch im unterricht einige
länder erhöhen oder führen ein doch sehr
drastische bußgelder auch wenn keine
maske getragen wird
wo auf welchen erkenntnissen genau
beruht eigentlich auch ihre einschätzung
dass die sorgen die man früher hatte bei
der schutzmaske dass man die nicht
richtig gebraucht dass sie vielleicht
eine falsche sicherheit vortäuscht dass
die inzwischen weniger wiegen als die
von ihnen vorhin auch erwähnten als der
von ihnen vorhin auch erwähnte nutzen
einer schutzmaske fried das ist
tatsächlich eine der großen ja auch
wissenschaftlichen herausforderungen die
erkenntnisse rund ums masken tragen weil
rein also wenn man es idealtypisch
machen wollen würde studie randomisiert
doppelblind müsste man über einen
längeren zeitraum sozusagen eine eine
population einen bevölkerungsteil ein
bereich eine region ohne maske und ein
mit maske wo auch immer auf der welt
dann miteinander vergleichen über einen
längeren zeitraum das ist natürlich so
in der reinen lehre nicht möglich
deswegen gibt es eine ganze reihe von
studien und wissenschaftlichen
untersuchungen die eben
infektionsgeschehen in ländern und
regionen und städten mit entsprechenden
alltags masken verpflichtungen auch im
vergleich setzen mit dem regionen
städten oder zeiträumen wo das nicht der
fall war und eben über die zeit zu der
erkenntnis gekommen sind und das war
tatsächlich ein wissenschaftlicher
erkenntnis gewinnen dass das tragen von
alltags masten
einen positiven unterschied macht es
reduziert das risiko nicht auf null das
finde ich ja immer wieder wichtig zu
sagen aber es erhöht die sicherheit
insbesondere da wo in geschlossenen
räumen abstand nicht eingehalten werden
kann
auch das finde ich wichtig und das
müssen wir auch richtung herbst winter
das wollen wir auch in dem auch was wir
kommunizieren in den angeboten und
hinweisen die wir für den alltag geben
mit der wissenschaft mit den experten
die dinge noch einmal weiterentwickeln
auch sehr deutlich zu machen wo macht
masken sagt tragen sind und wo nicht
weil wenn sie das nicht differenzieren
und kommunizieren dann tritt die
ermüdung natürlich umso schneller ein
wenn ich einige radfahrer manchmal
morgens hier in berlin alleine radeln
mit der maske sehe ist das natürlich
okay aber es macht jetzt keinen
unterschied weil das infektionsrisiko
dar so oder so bei null mehr oder
weniger ist in anderen bereichen wo ich
mir eine maske wünschen würde gibt es
eher so eine unbesorgt heidjann bildern
die wir sehen deswegen das machen wir
jeden tag auch in der nachsteuerung auch
in der begleitung ja das ist ja auch die
krone bunt studio und andere studien die
wir machen um zu sehen wie welche
maßnahme auch wahrgenommen wird und und
und beachtet wird muss man das eben sehr
zielgerichtet machen und auch
kommunizieren um das auf dauer auch
erhalten zu können
aber im kern ihre frage ja woher wir das
nehmen eben aus einer reihe auch
international vergleichender
wissenschaftlicher studien die einen
mehrwert der alltags masken
herausgearbeitet haben deswegen hat die
verona ihre position verändern die glas
heute morgen dass der präsident der eben
der weltgesundheit der welt des welt
ärzteverbandes herr montgomery ja auch
gesagt hat er hat seine position eben
durch neue erkenntnisse in der frage
überarbeitet und das ist genau das was
ich vor einigen woche mal meinte mit
einigen aussagen wir alle lernen in
einer solchen situation mit einem virus
das wir so noch nicht hatten und schon
gar nicht so eine weltweit und in einer
so komplexen modernen gesellschaft jeden
tag dazu
und bei den masken den alltags massen
war das ohne frage
seit januar so
die ard hörfunk
zwei fragen an den minister herr spahn
erstens die testpflicht soll ab samstag
gelten war es für sie nicht früher
möglich dass ins werk zu setzen oder die
notwendigkeit so nicht absehbar 2 es
wird in diesen tagen viel über zuschauer
in stadien geredet nächste woche soll es
dazu beratungen geben
im lichte der aktuellen zahlen halten
sie das für angemessen
zum einen zu der frage der test
vielleicht die ab samstag gilt es mir
sehr wichtig noch einmal darauf
hinzuweisen dass wir für den umgang mit
risikogebieten seit monaten eine
regelung haben man jetzt nicht sehen
aber in mancher öffentlicher äußerungen
habe ich schon den eindruck es wird so
getan als hätten wir uns mit
risikogebieten noch nie beschäftigt
natürlich beschäftigen wir uns seit dem
ersten tag seit den ersten fällen in
china ja auch mit risiko gebieten wo er
insbesondere und dort gilt eben und gilt
auch weiterhin die zweiwöchige
quarantäne verpflichtung für rückkehrer
und gleichzeitig haben wir gesehen dass
eben durch reiserückkehrer und zwar
nicht nur in deutschland sondern es war
ja dann ein phänomen auch in europa
insgesamt eben auch wieder stärkerer
eintrag stattgefunden hat wir sind
allerdings zu einem zeitpunkt jetzt wo
aus den meisten risikogebieten nach
europa und nach deutschland noch relativ
strikten reisebeschränkungen gelten also
für testpflicht aus risikogebieten finde
ich sind wir im zeitablauf sehr gut weil
die europäische union sich mit dem ende
der sommerpause beschäftigen wird mit
der frage wie geht s tatsächlich mit dem
reisen aus drittstaaten also nicht eu
ländern weiter und das einreise aus
nicht eu länder für nicht eu bürger ist
tatsächlich bis heute ja mit sehr
starken restriktionen belegt genau aus
diesem grund und deswegen kommt aus
meiner sicht die testpflicht
auch zu einem passenden zeitpunkt die
zweite frage war die nach den
fußballspielen und den konzepten die es
da gibt das konzept der dfl deutsche
fußball liga ist auch wir haben ja auch
durchaus als bundesministerium für
gesundheit kontakt und austausch gehabt
dort das robert koch institut und die
kollegen her aus dem ministerium mit der
fußball liga das konzept auch das weiter
entwickelte konzept ist finde ich ein
sehr gutes auch in vielerlei hinsicht in
der ausarbeitung beispielhaft in der
frage anreise abreise sitzplätze
nachvollziehbarkeit wer hat gesessen
wir haben sehr großen wert darauf gelegt
dass auch in stadion eineinhalb meter
abstand gewährleistet werden müssen das
ist das konzept zum beispiel noch mal
überarbeitet worden und viele
alkoholverbot vieles andere mehr
das ist nur entscheidend ist auf dem
platz und das konzept ist erstmal ein
theoretisches ist auf dem papier
und hier kommt jetzt darauf an was ist
tatsächlich dann gelebte realität im
stadion und und das ist ja die
eigentliche herausforderung auf dem weg
ins stadion und raus aus dem stadion
da kommt es natürlich auch sehr darauf
an über welche menschenmengen zahl wir
sozusagen geräten geht es um 5.000 also
wenn 5000 leute im stadion in dortmund
bei 70.000 kapazität sitzen oder 30.000
da sitzen das macht dann schon ein
unterschied in der an und in der abreise
und deswegen finde ich es sehr wichtig
dass dieses konzept der fußball liga
jetzt eben mit den behörden vor ort in
landes und den gesundheitsbehörden vor
ort auf das jeweilige stadion angepasst
wird
ein stadion in dortmund sieht anders aus
als ein stadion in leipzig oder auch
manches zweitliga stadion und umgekehrt
und dass das tatsächlich auch in allen
stadien gewährleistet werden kann dass
das gelebt wird und weil es auch daher
konzepte einzelner vereine gab das test
kapazitäten jetzt nicht originär in das
ermöglichen von zuschauern bei
bundesligaspielen geht wir brauchen die
test kapazitäten gerade vor allem für
den schutz im gesundheitswesen
wir brauchen ihn da wo es darum geht
auch patienten zu schützen wir brauchen
ihn wo es darum geht ausbruchs cluster
nachzuvollziehen sie ihre güter
wir brauchen es um das risiko des
eintrags zu verhindern siehe debatte zur
reise rückkehr
da möchte ich jetzt nicht konzepte sehen
wo wir zigtausende tests brauchen um
zuschauer bei fußballspielen möglich zu
machen das ist nicht bestandteil in
diesem in dieser herangehensweise des
dfl konzept aber es gibt ja vereine die
tatsächlich damit planen und ich finde
im moment jedenfalls ist nicht die zeit
dafür
also zusammengefasst entscheidend gutes
konzept ist auf dem platz muss das jetzt
tatsächlich mit den behörden vor ort
weiterentwickelt werden und dann eben am
ende so überzeugend sein dass das
infektionsrisiko weitestgehend minimiert
erst ein paar die hauptstadtstudio einer
frage zu einem anderen aber auch sehr
wichtigen thema seit einem jahr ersparen
gibt es jetzt die liste der
bundesärztekammer die aus dem
werbeverbote 219 hervorgegangen ist da
haben sich jetzt 327 praxen eintragen
lassen es gibt für 19.000 gynäkologen in
deutschland wie ist ihr fazit dieser
liste und viele praxen befürchten
drangsalierung bedrohungen wenn sie sich
da eintragen lassen
wie könnte der staat diese praxen
eventuell auch besser schützen
sie setzt sich ein völlig anderes thema
als das zu aktuellen infektionsgeschehen
der kompromiss zum 219 adm in der
koalition gefunden haben übrigens
mehrere bestandteile hatte
es ging ja auch um die frage der
qualifikation und
qualifikationsmöglichkeiten zum
schwangerschaftsabbruch wo wir mit der
ärztekammer und anderen beteiligten den
letzten monaten ein konzept überarbeitet
haben dass ich jetzt auch den
kolleginnen kollegin der bundesregierung
hat über senden können dieser tage sehr
wichtiges thema weil ich finde dass
frauen in dieser schwierigen lage auch
sicher sein können müssen dass sie
entsprechend dann auch mit guter
fachlicher qualität dann auch begleitet
werden medizinisch das zweite ist die
liste die für sich genommen schon mal
ein transparenz gewinn ist weil es
vorher das überhaupt nicht gab
aber natürlich ist das sich eintragen
lassen auf der liste freiwillig für die
ärztinnen und ärzte und die
entsprechenden einrichtungen und ich bin
sehr dankbar für das engagement der
ärztekammer und der entsprechenden
fachärzte verbände die dafür werben sich
entsprechend eintragen zu lassen dadurch
ist die zahl schon erhöht worden und ich
haben vereinbart mit den verbänden nach
der sommerpause dass wir uns noch mal
zusammensetzen und schauen wo stehen wir
nach dem kompromiss das was vereinbart
war aber eben auch insbesondere mit
blick auf dieser liste
und wie können wir dort transparenz und
die zahl und die bereitschaft sich zu
melden das was sie angesprochen haben
auch weiter erhöhen
grundsätzlich gilt natürlich gelten die
rechtlichen rahmenbedingungen die wenn
jemand seine meinung äußert an einer
bestimmten stelle in deutschland dann
ist das erlaubt wenn es um gewalt
drangsalierung beleidigung geht dann ist
das strafrechtlich bewährt die
regelungen dazu sind da mein eindruck
ist und das finde ich mach's schwer
auch in dieser gesellschaftlich ja sehr
strittig auch emotional strittigen frage
war auch vor der liste gab es ja schon
entsprechende bedrohungen und die sind
natürlich nicht zu akzeptieren
ich finde am ende ist es wichtig
unterschiedliche positionen
auszutauschen im gespräch miteinander zu
sein ich stelle fest dass gerade bei
diesem emotional sehr belasteten thema
das gespräch miteinander vielen immer
schwerer fällt das war in den neunzigern
da war ich noch klein aber ja schon so
rund um diesen kompromiss und das ist
bis heute so und deswegen finde ich ist
der kompromiss an sich den wir gefunden
haben in der koalition schon ein wert
weil er ein gesellschaftlich sehr
umstrittenes thema eben durch
kompromisse auch sucht zu befriedigen
erstens um verständnis
wenn also ein ein reisender aus den usa
am flughafen sagt er will kein test
machen
wie wird der test durchgesetzt und was
für ein bußgeld gibt es wenn man es
nicht tut und zu den schulen
es gibt ja die befürchtung dass die sich
auch zum raster für infektionen
entwickeln könnten
was halten sie denn von dem vorschlag
teilweise punktuelle oder
stichprobenartige tests an schulen
durchzuführen gegebenenfalls auch
sogenannte gruppen test die
hocheffizienz sein können
zum einen die testpflicht kommt mit
einem bußgeld wie alle regeln des
infektionsschutzgesetzes das habe ich
gerade schon gesagt bußgeld ist möglich
aber das ist natürlich dann immer nach
der verhältnismäßigkeit durch die
behörde vor ort zu entscheiden bis zu
25.000 euro
das heißt aber jetzt nicht dass gleich
jeder gleich die rechnung über 25.000
euro bekommt sondern wie gesagt es ist
eine entscheidung der behörde vor ort zu
nach verhältnismäßigkeit und wichtig ist
und bleibt ich sage es gerne auch zum
fünften mal weil es mir sehr wichtig ist
dass die botschaft wirklich ankommt bei
allen wer keine negativ test hat muss
zwei wochen in quarantäne
also wer das gefühl hat ich bin
irgendwie bockig verweigert am flughafen
aus einem risikogebiet zurückkehren und
dann hab ich erstmal hinter mir bis der
bußgeldbescheid kommt nein quarantäne
und charakter in der pflicht die dann
eben auch mit den entsprechenden
maßnahmen kommt und kommen kann was die
frage angeht der repräsentativen testung
an schulen machen dass er viele
bundesländer sachsen hat ja montag noch
testung aus den letzten wochen eine
studie vorgestellt und dabei angekündigt
wie andere bundesländer auch jetzt mit
start der schule mit schulbeginn über
die nächsten wochen und monaten
repräsentative testung zu machen in
schulen und den kitas um tatsächlich zu
sehen und das ist finde ich auch wichtig
für die wissenschaftliche erkenntnis
weil bis jetzt ist hier immer noch
ausbaufähig zu der frage was tragen
schulen und kitas tatsächlich bei zum
infektionsgeschehen das ist eben
tatsächlich solche studien stattfinden
und das wollte ich das wahrnehmen
ich weiß nicht was alle 16 machen aber
viele der bundesländer machen genau
solche studien und viele der
bundesländer haben ja das freiwillige
angebot an die erzieherin und der ziele
und lehrerinnen und lehrer sich
regelmäßig alle teilweise ein welche
teilweise zweiwöchige ein zwei wochen
sich testen zu lassen
die nächste frage hat und danach der
herr minister es gibt berichte noch mal
zu den gesundheitsämtern zurück dass da
ziemlich strenge anordnungen getroffen
werden was kinder betrifft wenn dann
corona verdacht besteht dass da in der
innerhalb der wohnung die kinder
isoliert werden und nicht gemeinsam mit
den gegessen werden soll usw
der kinderschutzbund vorige woche
aufgebracht wurde gab es wieder eine
neue berichte dazu halten sie so was
wenn es dann so stimmt für
verhältnismäßig oder ist das ein
bisschen überzogen
jetzt muss ich tatsächlich zugesteht
dass derartige berichte mich noch nicht
erreicht haben was jetzt die situation
also eine eine separierung innerhalb der
familie des eigenen hausstandes angeht
klar ist dass am ende ja dass die
debatte hatten wir übrigens auch schon
im februar märz rund um die massnahmen
bezogen auf die einzelnen haushalte am
ende so wenn jemand im haushalt
infiziert ist
dann sind idealerweise alle zwei wochen
zu hause um entsprechend
infektionsrisiken für andere zu
reduzieren außerhalb des haushaltes und
ich denke mal das ziel ist
möglicherweise genau das zu vermeiden
dass alle zwei wochen zu hause bleiben
müssen aber an der stelle müsste ich
tatsächlich erst noch einmal schauen was
da jetzt die aktuelle tatsächliche lage
ist jenseits von überschriften oder
ticker meldung
was die frage angeht eine andere frage
die viele beschäftigt hat mit blick auf
die kinder ist ja was ist wenn ein kind
schnupfen pustet leichte symptome hat
müssen dann alle gleich zu hause bleiben
dort haben die kolleginnen kollegen in
den ländern auch ich finde in sehr guten
gesprächen mit den entsprechenden kinder
ärzten mit den kitas mit elternverbänden
gute lösungen gefunden am ende müssen
wir alle jeden tag ich meine das ist das
was das virus die lage von uns im moment
verlangt jeden tag die balance finden
den kompromiss zwischen sicherheit so
viel wie möglich absolute sicherheit
gibt es nie und gleichzeitig alltag so
weit als möglich chancen so weit als
möglich wirtschaftliches öffentliches
leben so weit als möglich möglich zu
machen
und jede entscheidung ob kita und schule
ob die frage ob flüge stattfinden und
wie sie stattfinden jede dieser
entscheidung ist am ende das finden und
suchen der richtigen balance zwischen
sicherheit und alltag möglich mal jubeln
von der bild zeitung ich würde mich gern
meinem kollegen anschließen das thema
wollte ich auch ansprechend es gibt im
speziellen um zwei landkreise in baden
württemberg und hessen glaube ich die
verordnen dass kinder separiert
unterzubringen sind wenn sie denn coco
mit 19 positiv sind und auch die
mahlzeiten getrennt stattfinden sollen
aber zuwiderhandlungen sollen die kinder
für die zeit der quarantäne gar der
familie herausgenommen in geschlossenen
anstalten gebracht werden und natürlich
jetzt seine angst von familien ist wenn
ich ein positiv besetztes kind zu hause
habe dass mir das weggenommen wird für
zwei wochen halten sie solche maßnahmen
für verhältnismäßig da ich hab ich ja
gerade schon gesagt bisher keine
kenntnis von diesen maßnahmen und
umständen habe sehen sie es mir nach
dass ich mich tatsächlich erstmal
informieren weil ich finde in zeiten wie
diesen wo diejenigen die vor ort
verantwortung haben und die entscheidung
treffen ist jeden tag nicht leicht haben
unter stress entscheidungen zu treffen
sollte der bundesminister nicht ohne den
sachverhalt zu kennen
irgendwie schon bewertende bemerkungen
machen das wird der arbeit vor ort nicht
gerecht deswegen eigentlich erstmal
schlau und dann und dann bilde ich mir
die meinung dass ich hab jetzt ziehen
und mal und frisch und den kollegen von
rtl hat sich erledigt ok und dann würde
ich die frageliste schließen
herr spahn ich weiß nicht ob sie die
frage nach den kosten nach der
kostenübernahme schon beantwortet haben
könnten sie mir sagen wer für diese
kostenlosen tests jetzt aufkommt sind
dass die krankenkassen die das bezahlen
das heißt er meine erste frage wenn sie
die vielleicht bitte nochmal oder
beantworten würden und die zweite ist
wenn sie von der verhältnismäßigkeit
sprechen der bußgelder
wer muss denn dann ein 25.000 euro
bußgeld gewärtigen und wer nur 1 150
euro woran bemisst sich denn das danke
das ist am ende eine entscheidung der
behörden vor ort wie hoch welches
bußgeld ist das hängt von den konkreten
umständen daneben auch ab das gilt ja
auch für andere bereiche des
infektionsschutzgesetzes wenn sie zum
beispiel einer verpflichtenden impfungen
das erste mal nicht nachkommen wird das
bunte bußgeld ein anderes sein als wenn
sie zum zwanzigsten mal sich verweigern
und hier wird es zum beispiel ähnliche
parameter daneben auch geben und sich
mit sicherheit entwickeln
gleichwohl bleibe ich dabei ich weiß
dass solche fragen über sanktionen und
bußgeld immer tatsächlich auch die sind
sie dann den fokus
kommen ich bin sehr sicher dass dieser
verpflichtenden testung die weit über
große zahl der rückkehrer aus
risikogebieten oder der einreisenden aus
risikogebieten auch nachkommen wird am
ende dann tatsächlich eben sich
sozusagen freiwillig in die pflicht
tugend weil sie eben tatsächlich für
sich und andere auch den mehrwert sehen
dass die frage der kosten angeht ist es
ja so dass durch den nachtragshaushalt
denn der deutsche bundestag für 2020
beschlossen hat 3,5 milliarden euro
zusätzliches steuergeld in die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung bereits
fließen
wir haben darüber hinaus vereinbart dass
die steuerzuschüsse für 20 21 für das
nächste jahr sowohl in die kranken die
pflegeversicherung auch erhöht werden um
die beiträge zu stabilisieren aber eben
auch um corinna bedingte mehrausgaben
die nicht originäre
krankenkassenausgaben sind entsprechend
auszugleichen und insofern wird es im
moment abgewickelt sozusagen in der
praktischen abwicklung über die
liquidität liquiditätsreserve des
gesundheitsfonds und den mitteln dort
die speist sich aber zu nicht geringen
teilen aus dem bundeszuschuss und damit
aus steuermitteln richtig deswegen sage
ich übrigens auch immer es ist kostenlos
für den einzelnen nicht nichts ist
kostenlos am ende muss jemand auch einen
solchen test finanzieren
das gilt aber auch für alle anderen
tests die wir finanzieren für jeden in
bestimmten situationen definierten die
eben finanziert werden sie werden dann
von uns allen getragen zum schutz des
einzelnen aber ich sage auch noch einmal
zum schutz von uns allen
es liegt in unser aller interesse
infektionsketten frühstmöglich zu
unterbrechen und infektionen zu erkennen
wir tragen übrigens sehen die sehen die
das fluss schäden hat es robert koch
institutes unter daraus folgende
kostentragung von tests schon seit
monaten die kostenübernahme vor im
zusammenhang mit risikogebieten also
manche debatte die sich den letzten zwei
wochen ergeben hat die ich sage noch
einmal ich verstehe emotional sagt man
klar wer in der karibik war der kann
sich doch dann auch den test noch dazu
leisten würde ich intuitiv auch sofort
ja klar sagen
aber wenn sie dann halt ein bisschen
tiefer dahinter gehen was das alles ist
in folge wirkung hat und dass die
meisten reisenden nicht die karibik
reisenden sind die man zuerst assoziiert
mit einer solchen aussage sondern viele
bei reisebeginn und reiseplanung gar
nicht wissen konnten und wussten zum
beispiel ob es das jetzt ein
risikogebiet ist oder nicht
viele sich dann wenn es zu sozialen und
zur finanziellen frage wird auch viel
mehr einer verpflichtenden testung
entziehen wollen werden
also hat ja alles ganz andere folgen in
dem moment wo es mit kosten entsprechend
verbunden ist inkasso fragen ich frage
mich manchmal und manch einer der solche
bemerkung macht sich mal mit inkasso
fragen auseinandergesetzt hat und was
das überhaupt so nach sich zieht wenn
sie das alles dann tatsächlich auch
nachvollziehen wollen dann komme ich
einfach ganz lebenspraktisch und aus
grundüberzeugung als bundesminister für
gesundheit zu dem ergebnis das macht
sinn dass wir das gemeinschaftlich
tragen die letzte frage noch mal ganz
praktische abwicklung dieser pflicht
tests ich steige aus führt eine
aussteiger karte aus ich lasse mir die
sofort testen gehen diese informationen
an das örtliche gesundheitsamt gehen sie
davon aus dass sie extrem proaktiv diese
fälle nachverfolgen erste frage und wie
optimistischer wie ist die reaktion
ihrer europäischen kollegen auf die idee
diese pflicht tests vor den toren
europas machen zu lassen
zum einen dass die frage der testung vor
einreise nach europa von
nicht-eu-bürgern natürlich müssen wir
eu-bürger einreisen lassen das steht
auch für mich völlig außer frage aber
dann eben mit quarantäne erfordernis aus
entsprechenden risiko gebieten ist
bestandteil der weiteren gespräche ich
weiß viele kolleginnen und kollegen
gesundheitsminister bereich die diesen
ansatz unterstützen
aber das ist tatsächlich eine
entscheidung die über die runde der
gesundheitsminister hinausgeht
wo aber jedenfalls meine position sehr
klar ist was die frage angeht
die ich schon wieder vergessen hatte
also die frage was ist was ist mit der
entsprechenden testung und ob die
behörden das umfangreiche testen werden
zu den behörden vor ort kommen also
unser ziel ist es ist ja tatsächlich und
das ist ja etwas was wir im rahmen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes sehr umfänglich
haben lernen müssen in den letzten
monaten
es ist noch sehr analog dieses gesetz
und auch die arbeit der öffentliche
gesundheitsämter war sehr analog wir
sind ja gerade dabei und vieles auch
schon gelungen ist in einem sehr zügigen
prozess auch zu digitalisieren und unser
ziel ist auch in den nächsten wochen
diesen prozess der aussteige karten zu
digitalisieren
mit dem bundesministerium des innern in
guter zusammenarbeit in dem
verkehrsministerium mit den ball da ist
natürlich auch sinn macht da nicht
papierkarten per se im flieger
auszufüllen sondern wie andere länder
das auch machen das vor abreise
idealerweise schon entsprechend
auszufüllen und dann auch ganz anders
natürlich verarbeitet werden kandidaten
um sie dann an die gesundheitsämter vor
ort zu bringen
für den stichproben prozess der angelegt
ist jetzt mit den karten händisch werden
tatsächlich auch bundesinstitutionen wie
die bundeswehr dort wo länder um
unterstützung bitten in amtshilfe für
die praktische abwicklung etwa am
flughafen frankfurt dann auch
entsprechende personelle unterstützung
geben damit aus den vielen aussteige
karten die ankommt die information wer
ist denn davon wo angekommen an das
zuständige gesundheitsamt vor ort auch
kommen kann
aber das eben tatsächlich nur in
stichprobe digital wird sie deutlich
umfangreicher möglichst gut dann vielen
dank danke ihm alles gute